I feel like eating me
world
the desire to move forward wanting to want
do different and unique things
do not
contextualize that has brought cultures
civilizations not important in the
history of egypt rome greece and everything
what does the world mean while a
little beyond not at the end much further
we who are very people
restless in many very many things
apart discipline methodology the whole is
possible teamwork respect the
another game that is today this can be one
and the citizen
is for me more exciting than there are in
no point the mind for this opaque
is with us because to mount a
wonderful reason and we can
contextualize we see understand and
understand and understand the Arab world
in this way we do everything much more
methodological much more efficient and
we can control the methods much more
creative we did not see him trying on your
cook a dish because here we go more
there at the end they take us the restlessness
you want to learn more, you have to know
plus
for me cooking gastronomy is a
way to understand life we ​​know a lot
more than with work, cook for me